We have this incredible group of
undergraduates, graduate students, and
medical students and doctors who
come here every week and provide direct
medical services to people who really
need them. Something that we do that is
really special is we provide them a
non-judgmental environment where we just
sit and are with them and I've had
clients come to me consistently saying
if people had treated them the way that
we do, they would have seen a doctor a
long time ago. I'm proud of the mobile
clinic project because it is completely
student-run so all the people that you
see here are students themselves from
three different schools.
We're from the Medical School, from the
public health school and undergraduate
school. So we're packaging vitamins for clients, and we pack a weeks supply so that way when clients
come they have enough to last them until
the next clinic. There's some clients
that I've got to know over my time here
and I love seeing them and having them
recognize me and we share a moment.
They're not prejudging anybody which is
great. They realize they have to deal with people that are at risk
and they treat them very good. I feel
like it makes medical school actually
seem kind of real because the past four
weeks you've been studying, going to
lecture, and those are things
that are really important to medicine,
but being able to use those two skills
and to give back is something that's
invaluable and really reminds
me why I decided to go into
medicine in the first place.